-It seems like we planned this,
but this has been scheduled
for a long time.
No one could have imagined,
a couple of months ago,
what happened today.
How does this feel?
How are you processing it
as a New Yorker?
-Yeah, well, I mean, there's as
an American and as a New Yorker.
As a New Yorker, it was a very
New York kind of day.
You have not just
what was happening
with former president Trump,
but then you have
MTG flying into town.
You've got, you know, just
the whole chaos of the scene
and also all the people
walking by like,
"Okay, I'm on my lunch break.
Time to go."
-Yeah.
-You know, it was --
it was just a lot.
It was a circus, right?
-I mean, your whole life,
this is a person who,
especially in New York,
has been investigated,
never charged,
you know, multiple,
you know, certainly accusations
of financial improprieties.
Did you ever think
this day would come
where he would be arraigned,
especially for things like,
you know, the misuse of money?
-Yeah, I mean,
I think I had always felt
that something might happen.
Honestly,
I think if something did,
I would have thought
it would be something like this,
around falsification of business
documents or some sort of charge
that has to do
with documentation or finances.
But, I mean,
my dad was an architect.
He worked in construction
and in that industry.
And from the time
I was a kid,
it's like no one knew this guy
better than New Yorkers.
And just like this is just --
People would have thought
this is what he would have been
in for before he was president.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, I think it does
feel like a matter of course.
I also think that --
I mean, listen,
this is not about guaranteeing
one outcome or another.
This is about due process,
and the lack of process of,
I think, a formal due process
for so long
really created
this question of,
"Do we really have
an equal society,
no matter your income,
no matter how powerful you are?"
And I think the presence
of this process demonstrates
that we should have one law
that applies to all people,
no matter who you are
or where you come from.
[ Cheers and applause ]